auf diesen moment habe ich lange
gewartet dass sich an diesem tisch mit
thomas hürlimann zusammensitze zukommen
versprochen hat er mir schon lang aber
immer kam etwas dazwischen
seine arbeit seine schwere krankheit die
poetikvorlesungen in wien
aber jetzt ist er da einer der
bedeutendsten schriftsteller der schweiz
unzählige preise hat er gewonnen in über
20 sprachen ist ein berg übersetzt
thomas hürlimann ist für mich einer der
streitbarsten intellektuellen der
schweiz und genau deshalb interessiert
mich einer der nie geliebt und das
christliche kreuz verteidigt einer der
im kloster einen autisten club gründete
und heute die leeren kirchen beklagt
einer der anstand und sitte vermisst und
selber gern ein bisschen casanova war
und einer der über regenschirme
philosophiert er hört man ganz herzlich
willkommen
danke schön herr juni mann aus theater
machen haben sie natürlich ihre requisit
gleich selber mitgebracht das ist ein
roter regenschirm in dem eine menge
philosophie und auch gleich noch mit
drin steckt wo fangen wir an
ja man muss vielleicht sagen dass
nietzsche immer mit einem regenschirm
gewandert ist
er hat ja gesagt es ist jeden gedanken
zu misstrauen der nicht im wandel
angepasst ist und sein denken wurde von
einem schirm begleitet er hat sich so
wahrscheinlich seine schlechten abwägen
gegen die sonne geschützt und der schirm
der ist aber ja eben nicht nur ein
regenschirm und einen schirm gegen die
sonne wie er das heute ist sondern der
schirm hat eine ganz große geschichte
auch eine kulturelle geschichte um diese
geschichte erzählen sie auch zusammen
mit der geschichte von nietzsches
regenschirm in diesem wunderbaren
büchlein und dieses büchlein als ich das
gelesen habe habe ich gedacht darüber
möchte ich mit ihm sprechen nein ich
finde das passt eigentlich fast schon so
ein bisschen irre denkrichtung ihre denk
ströme ganz wunderbar zusammen
also reden wir mal über diesen schirm
graf ist denn los woher kommt dieser
schirm eigentlich ursprünglich also
ursprünglich war er eine art von stress
reichen also die vornehmen die edlen
hatten so etwas wie einen schirm sklaven
und wurden vom führungskräften begleitet
also dass eine eine vornehme
persönlichkeit zeichnete sich auch
dadurch aus dass sie eben diesen schirm
träger hatte was man heute noch sieht in
der gleichen namens prozession mit dem
baldachin und jetzt muss man sich fragen
was ist eben der schirm
weshalb ist er für den als zeichen
wichtig weil er nicht nur zum boden
verweist sondern eben auch in die höhe
also der schirm wenn er uns schützt ist
gleichzeitig ein zeichen nach oben
dass der französische philosoph jacques
derrida hat vom mittel wesen gesprochen
aber ein schirm schwebt sozusagen
zwischen der himmel und der erde
er ist fast eine stufe höher als der
mensch selber er verbindet uns mit dem
zentralraum wie ein engel mittel wesen
weil er einerseits eben nach oben
verweist wie gesagt haben sie haben die
fronleichnamsprozession erwähnt also da
wird ja die hostien durch die straßen
getragen und darüber wird ein baldachin
getragen als zeichen dieser transzendenz
und gleichzeitig mit jacques derrida das
mittel wesen schirm ist er eben auch ein
wanderstab ein wanderstab ganz recht und
wenn sie das anschauen
vielleicht kennt man nachdem es klappt
stab von der apotheke das ist ja die
schlange der mensch war der frühe
wanderung war durch die schlange
gefährdet also hat er einen stab
genommen um die schlangen weg zu klopfen
so sind sie wohl so war sein weg sicher
und gleichzeitig hat er die schlangen in
die senkrechte gezwungen symbolisch mit
diesem bogen also die schlange muss sich
in den eigenen schwanz beißt das denken
sie sich jetzt aus dass hat sich nicht
ein schirrmacher ausgegangen
die schirrmacher haben wahrscheinlich
gedacht wie liebt das gut in der hand
aber ursprünglich zum beispiel der
bischofsstab
er hat ja auch diese eigentlich diese
schlange also der mensch besiegt
eigentlich mit dem sektor mit dem
bischofsstab herrscht er über die welt
auf der geht also das ist gar nicht nur
an chris sondern das ist eine schlange
und hat damit zu tun dass man die
schlangen welt besiegt dass man die
schlangen welt geschickt ja und
gleichzeitig wird jetzt sozusagen von
der schlange welt in die vogelwelt kann
man sich die vogelwelt erheben mit oder
der schirm erhebt sich der entfaltet
sich in die vogelwelt man spricht heute
noch so es überhaupt schirm fricke noch
gibt von kiel und das waren ursprünglich
federkiele also dass da hatte das innere
der feder hat man genommen um den schirm
zu bauen um bildschirm zu bauen ja alle
mit mit den mit dem federkiel oder auch
dass das amt das dach einer party nach
das amt eine palme nach aber es ist eben
auch eine art von flügel wie ein
engelsflügel und so hat man früher zum
beispiel nicht china die seiten schirme
sehr oft auch mit himmels ornamenten mit
sternen und so weit wird bemalt ähnlich
wie ein mantel
das heißt der schirm steht zwischen der
erde die er beherrscht und zwischen dem
himmel oder schrift dazwischen auf denen
hinweist wie ein kronen verkäufer man ja
schon schlimm haben ja dass es gab
natürlich früher ganz viele schirme das
ist leider vorbei als dieser text
erschienen ist habe ich gerade zufällig
gelesen hat in deutschland der letzte
firma aufgegeben
also es gibt jetzt praktisch nur noch in
england den schirm der ihnen dann
individuell angemessen wird auf die
richtige größe mit dem richtigen griff
die engländer müssen das noch noch zu
schätzen und
das hat etwas auch damit zu tun dass der
schirm früher eigentlich dem arzt
gehörte im 16 jahrhundert hat dann der
bürger sich selber einen scherung
zugetan
allerdings ohne schirm sklaven er kann
er richtig gleich den konnte er sich
nicht leisten ehrt weit sein schirm
denselben und diese tradition hat sich
in england bis heute gehalten
jetzt müssen wir vielleicht mal
enthüllen warum sie eigentlich genau
nietzsche und den schirm in einem buch
verpacken weil das eine ist ja dass sie
sagten nietzsche ging nie ohne
regenschirm spazieren und er war ja ein
ganz großer spaziere ich das auch gerade
am anfang gesagt haben aber es gibt ja
noch einen weiteren grund gibt nämlich
im nachlass von nietzsche eine notiz man
weiß eigentlich nicht so recht woher die
stammt aber es ist ein einzelner zettel
auf dem einfach nur steht ich habe
meinen schirm vergessen doch nicht
verloren sondern vergessen vergessen und
sie machen daraus eine interessante
wendung eigentlich erzählen sie finde
ich fast ein bisschen die geschichte von
manager der seinen job verliert ja
dieser schirm ist nicht mehr da man
könnte ja sagen wenn man das schirm
bildet man so deutet die sich jetzt
getan haben auch mit dem weißen in den
himmel zu gott hin dass nietzsche ja den
schirm zwangsläufig verlieren muss der
nie gesagt ja gott ist tot
das ist sehr wichtig ich muss vielleicht
dazu sagen dass dieser satz ich habe
meinen schirm vergessen vermutet man
könnte eine der letzten schriftlichen
sätze von ihnen gewesen sein eventuell
geschrieben
unterwegs zwischen turin und basel wo er
sein freund oberbeck dann irgendwie
psychiatrische klinik gebracht hat
nietzsche hatte einen zusammenbruch in
turin und zwar ist er einem pferd das
von seinem coach ob das ein wunden über
seite kurz oder also das pferd
gepeitscht weil es warum zusammenbrechen
es konnte nicht mehr weiter und lieferte
er über diesen platz ging rannte auf das
pferd zu und hat es umarmt und meine
these ist wenn man ein pferd umarmt
an den schirm fallen und der blieb als
auf diese patzer in turin liegen und
nietzsche wurde dann nach hause gebracht
und einer seiner letzten klaren gedanken
könnte eben diesen vergessenen requisit
gelten dem sie jetzt ein denkmal gesetzt
haben in diesem kleinen seite eine eine
vermutung und es hat eben etwas damit zu
tun was sie vorhin angesprochen haben
nietzsche hat gott für tot erklärt und
hat dann aber gemerkt wenn ich dort
abschaffe dann schaffe ich auch meine
seele ab dann bin ich das was dann was
zur gleichen zeit etwas später vor heute
gesagt habe ein wesen das aus einem
betrieb und perfekte system besteht eine
ähnliche krise machte rilke durch da ist
es dann der himmel lose engel also ein
nietzsche rilke sie für ihren den himmel
und stellen dann aber fest dass sie
eigentlich trotzdem von ihrer eigenen
seele oder von einer seelischen
befindlichkeit nicht loskommen sie
geraten also in einen widersprochen
hinein bei rilke sind das dann die
duineser elegien die daraus entstehen
und bei und nietzsche erzählt davon
hauptsächlich in excel roma also sein
sozusagen abschieds buch war über sein
ganzes werk spricht und da ist zu sehen
wenn man die werte wie er das wollte um
mehrwert also früher waren die ideen das
reine die wahrheit gott nie geklärt es
dann um werde das uns hat nein meine
effekte meine triebe sind rein
die diese ideen dass diese ideen welt
das ist lüge das ist illusion das ist
täuschung und in dieser umwertung der
werte begibt er sich ins jenseits von
gut und böse
das nennt er dann das gefährliche
vielleicht und entdeckt dann
dass er aber sozusagen die den rissen
sich die teilung in sich jetzt müssen
wir glaube ich genau sind wir mittendrin
in einer riesigen meter welt wir sind
raten umriss ja da haben wir immer ganz
kurz noch stehen bei dieser nische der
diese umwertung der werte vz und ich
möchte gerne mal kurz zu ihnen wechseln
sie selber haben ja diese diese
umwertung der werte eigentlich nicht
auch selber auch vollzogen sie waren
klosterschüler und gingen dann weg sie
haben philosophie studiert in berlin
und sie sagen auch sie haben sich da
eigentlich eine weile lang dem dem
nihilismus nietzsches an die brust
geworfen sind damit aber nicht wirklich
glücklich geworden
reisen selber jeden wie diesen riss
entdeckt haben oder was hat ihnen
gefehlt
ja das ist eine schwierige frage
ich glaube gemerkt habe ich es in einem
zustand der verliebtheit also wenn man
zusehen wie nature wenn man sagt also
das absolute ist eine täuschung ist eine
illusion
ich habe mich also so fasst der aus dem
glauben hinaus mit geben wenn ich dachte
also sozusagen in nationalistischen
weltbild und dann auch erfahrung nicht
so sehr den ideologien aber ich dachte
wirklich ich muss mich von der
transzendenz verabschieden also in einem
moment in ein einheitliches denkt bild
und dann habe ich festgestellt ja was
ist eigentlich mit der liebe wenn man
plötzlich in eine frau verliebt es sind
so viele andere um einen herum dann
fragt man sich ja wieso hat diese eine
was was ist da eigentlich passiert und
dann hatte ich eine sehr schöne
vorlesung bei professor land das war ein
schweiz und der eu
großartige professor und bei der die
kette in berlin ja ja und und und und er
hat dann das war eine planung vorlesung
da waren wir nur noch so sechs oder
sieben damals also ein marxistisch und
und und alle platon das war schnee von
vorgestern aber was konnte platon
erklären dass eben unsere seele in einem
vorgeburtlichen raum alles schon
geschaut hat cg jung nennt ist an die
auch niemals das wort kommt schon bei
platten vor
da begegnet sozusagen die seele einem
animus einer anima und wenn man dann der
verkörperung einer solchen figur einer
solchen auch immer eines ali muss auf
dieser welt begegnet war nachts block
und das ist sie
das ist er das ist sozusagen
vorbestimmung die fia die wieder
erinnerungen an das einst oder forschung
schon geschaut
also bat das hat alles ist wieder regen
und wir haben alles schon gesagt und was
wir dann auf dieser welt erleben das
holen wir dann aus dem von aber kann
dafür unser lehrer passieren kann man in
mehrere solche begegnungen haben
vielleicht ich also es ist eben so
wir haben bei den proben einen einzigen
zugang hat davon gesprochen
casanova was ich eine figur der für
viele frauen jetzt ein animus war dass
er hat in seiner zeit etwas körper auf
wo dann so viele wie vom blitz getroffen
worden weil die nachbarn ist liebe immer
auch liebe auf den ersten blick weil es
ja ein wiedererkennen ist das ist sie
ich weiß gar nicht woher woher ich das
weiß aber ich spüre es ich weiß es ich
bin von diesem moment an dieser verloren
obwohl verfahren und etwas davon hat
mich dann sozusagen
skeptisch gemacht als es war so ich habe
mich seltsamerweise in eine frau
verliebt die ute hieß und und die
steckte noch als kleiner restbestand im
wort dass absolute ferdinand sie
erkennen eine wunderbare geschichte es
hat alles in ihrem leben seinen sinn und
seine bedeutung
naja wenn man kann einfach seinem leben
wenn man wenn man wenn man es einordnet
bedeutungen auch geben das ist ja das
ist ja uns geben oder nein
ein schriftsteller die handbuch schreibt
der macht das auch für sie bestimmte
figuren mit motiven und mit mustern dass
also der leser auch weiß der verhält
sich in dieser situation meistens so
dann kann er mit leben und ich glaube
das können wir mit unserem leben ganz
ähnlich auch nach und gibt es die ute
noch in ihrem leben nein die gibt es
nicht mehr ich bin von ute sozusagen
zurück zum absoluten interessant die usa
sozusagen der übergang vom sagen dir
klosterschüler nie ließ muss dann kam
die gute und von der route ging wieder
zum absoluten also irgendwann haben sie
sozusagen ihren metaphysischen
regenschirm oder ihre metaphysischen
schirm wieder aufgespannt
ja ich habe ich plötzlich festgestellt
ich habe so etwas wie metaphysische
antennen und die zahlen ins leere
also ich habe diesen raum für mich
selber abgeschafft das war auch eine
auseinandersetzung mit meiner herkunft
mit großen schule
wir hatten sehr gut weil wir konnten
damals wirklich gegen eine vorhandene
macht
konnten wir antreten das ist in jungen
jahren etwas sehr schönes dann
rebellieren kann man rebellieren
wir sind dann allerdings schon in
einzel- und der stiftsschule erschrocken
weil wir gemerkt haben
dieses gebäude ist überhaupt nicht so
stark wie wir dass wir das gedacht haben
da also ist schon etwas morsch im gebälk
und das gebäude hat es uns dann
eigentlich leicht gemacht dagegen
anzurennen oder zusammen wir haben jetzt
plötzlich eine eigene bibliothek
ermöglicht
reinhard ersten club waren das tanzen
und feuerbach und wer auch immer und
eben nicht mehr aber ich dort aus und
glaubt und wie das ohne thomas von aquin
wie das von der schule her kam und mit
der neuen bibliothek hat nach einem
neuen schlüssel zur welt aber dann habe
ich festgestellt diese denke die stelle
mich letztlich nicht zufrieden
also ich vermisse diesen großen kosmos
den ich da verlassen habe und da fing
dann eine art von suche an wieder einen
zugang dazu zu senken und das ist ja
auch interessant sie haben von diesen
antennen die ins leere zappeln
gesprochen was sie ein schönes bild
glauben sie haben alle menschen
eigentlich diese antennen bei den
anderen zappeln sich einfach mehr als
bei den einen oder umgekehrt oder
glauben sie werden hat auch ab
antennendose wesen geboren
nein ich glaube das haben wir alle also
wir sind ja zum beispiel wenn wir ein
buch lesen
bereits auf dem weg ins imaginäre hinein
also dafür braucht die beamten wenn ich
ein buch lesen das ist eine buchstaben
welt aber jetzt in meiner vorstellung
wird das lebendig ich betrete also einen
imaginären raum der in meiner
vorstellung gegenständlich wird und
allein schon das lesen das betrachten
von bildern
das hören von musik ist eine art von
transzendenz das ist ein metaphysik
heißt ja nichts anderes als das was über
dem physischen liegt was darüber
hinausgeht und wenn wir eine person
hatte hören dann sind wir bereits in
einem anderen raum dann in ein magnet
ehrenbeamte aber konkret werde denn wir
hören den wir eintreten
und ich glaube jeder mensch hat diese
anfängt oder dieses eng sich da hinein
zu vergeben das ist eine sehnsucht sagen
sie nach transzendenz man kann das ja
unterschiedlich benennen es würde
wahrscheinlich auch viele autisten geben
die sagen natürlich habe ich auch dieses
gefühl des erhabenen wenn man jetzt auch
einmal wieder aufnehmen will er sagen
würde ja es berührt mich etwas ich habe
ich mir das gefühl als noch mehr aber
das kann ich auch erklären mit meinen
hirnströmen aber deswegen muss ich noch
nicht an einen gott glauben
bei ihnen ist aber der metaphysische
schirm dann schon stärker auch wirklich
auf eine gottes idee hin ausgerichtet ja
ich würde vielleicht vorsichtig sein mit
dem mit dem wort gott
darüber können wir eigentlich was kann
man keine aussagen darüber machen
das ist durch die definition das
göttlicher ist steht über uns und wir
können uns nicht gedanklich darüber
erheben und das sozusagen zum objekt und
zum gegenstand machen aber wir haben
tatsächlich zeichen ein solches zeichen
habe ich dann bei mädchen gesucht im
schirm wird dann auch eben dass die die
schlange und eröffnen das sind seine
wappentiere da kreuzt sich also kreuzen
sich seine beiden wappen tiere
taucht auch so etwas wie das kreuz auf
also derjenige der bob abgeschafft hat
trägt in der dauernd mit in diesem mit
diesem kreuz erwägt kommt nicht von ihm
los
sie kriegt keine chance gegen sie ist
immer noch einige jetzt bei ihnen
ich denke auch dass wir zum schluss also
wieder in der halle also sei einer
seiner letzten verrückten setzte heißt
ja lieber wäre ich brauch noch professor
geblieben als gott geworden und er hat
sich am schluss selbst verdeutlicht er
hat also seine letzten postkarten mit
der gekreuzigte unterschrieben also
diese eher der abschaffung von gott
wurde selber so etwas wie gott aber was
ich also vorher zu haben versuchte also
diese diesem versuch eigentlich über das
was wir sind hinaus zu denken oder eben
einer anderen welt die möglichkeit zu
geben dass ich mir begegnet also ich
könnte jetzt nicht sagen das ist das ist
aber also high tech gespräch davon sein
dass sein ist mehr als das seien
und in der dritten welt war es nun so
dass der grieche hat nicht über etwas
gedacht sondern hat sich eigentlich
zurückgelehnt und versuchte dann die
phänomene auf sich zukommen zu lassen
dass sie ihm begegnen dass ich ihm so
etwas wie das göttliche das imaginäre
das andere offenbar ein staunen und da
versuche ich auf ihre frage zu
beantworten nicht unbedingt
auszugleichen
ich versuche mich in solchen situationen
hinein zu bringen wollen wir ein staunen
möglich ist in der erwartung dass sich
für merck hier vielleicht etwas
offenbart von dem anderen über das ich
gar nichts sagen kann ich glaube ich
verstehe sehr gut was sie meinen also
sie sagen im grunde genommen sie wollen
überhaupt gar nicht als über bord
sprechen und sie wollen auch nicht den
anderen
die auch ein metaphysisches datteln von
antennen da irgendwie spüren absprechen
dass sie auch große erfahrungen machen
es geht gar nicht so sehr darum das zu
benennen
es gibt aber trotzdem eine sehr
interessante idee bei ihnen und zwar hat
die mit dem hier zu tun
ich habe nämlich auch ein schirm
mitgenommen sie sagen nämlich es ist
furchtbar traurig die leute haben keine
vernünftigen schirme mehr
ich fühlte mich leichter taugt sondern
nur noch schulstufen schirme die in der
kriegs und lohnstufe stecken geblieben
sind nämlich knirpse und ein bisschen
sei es auch so mit der religion wir
haben eigentlich eine schulstufe an
religiösen die irgendwie so ein eine
schulstufe einem nur noch ein so kleines
religiöses gefühl seine wellness
religion verkörpert das ist das was die
kirchen heute machen
ja es läuft genau es gibt klubs kirche
das ist er mitglied das ist die die die
kirche die sich vom ministerium entfernt
und das halte ich für eine ganz große
gefahr
wir können ja nicht sagen wir haben gott
wir wissen wo es langgeht aber wenn sie
zum beispiel eine kleine kapelle nehmen
oder das kann ein irgendein winkel in
einer drop ist ein ordnung eine was ich
besonders liebe kleine eine alte
bibliothek sie gehen in einen raum der
stille hinein und jetzt beginnt
plötzlich die andere welt zu ihnen zu
sprechen
also sie sind zum beispiel in einer
landung in italien und den dom herum ist
der verkehr sich in einer eigenartigen
stelle etwas ähnliches geschieht auf
einem friedhof und plötzlich spüren sie
da offenbart sich etwas
da tritt etwas ihnen entgegen botho
strauß spricht nicht von der offenbarung
aber von einer paarung das heißt ich
werde wieder fähig kein subjekt zu sein
dass die welt beherrscht sondern kann
diese andere welt gegenübertreten und
das ist natürlich nicht so leicht dafür
brauchen wir räume dafür brauchen wir
zeichen also ein religiöses symbol ist
ein solches fenster auf der einen seite
wenn ich jetzt ein kreuz betracht weil
ich muss es nicht mal anbieten
ich kann es betrachten und ich sehe
durch dieses kreuz hindurch das
sozusagen den tod und die auferstehung
von jesus symbolisiert durch das
hindurch in eine höhere wirklichkeit in
eine andere wirklichkeit ob ich haben
sie glauben oder nicht ist letztlich
egal
und genauso der prozess umgekehrt kann
mir jetzt diese höhere wirklichkeit
durch das zeichen begegnen
ich habe ihre kritik noch nicht
verstanden sie sagen es gibt diese
verkleinerung diese verknüpfungen des
religiösen weggeben vom ministerium
gegen zu diesem ins politische
moralisierende abgeleitete wellness
religion diesen dom den sie beschrieben
haben dann gibt es ja noch
also wo genau ist dieser schwund stufe
auszumachen
ja was sind das die leute die nicht mehr
bereit sind das ministerium zu suchen
oder wird das ministerium nicht mehr
angeboten
ich glaube es ist eine krise der kirche
meiner meinung nach hängt das damit an
dass man die katholische messe in dem
sinn dass ein
ein ästhetisches kunstwerk das ist über
den
der so viel trägt denn tierische messe
über die jahrhunderte immer noch mit dem
rücken zum volk lief zum volk ist er ist
der vertreter des volks wer gott spricht
und man sucht eigentlich jetzt genau in
dieser haltung eben das fenster das
symbol durch das dann uns die höhere
wirklichkeit begegnen kann
das hat man restlos abgeschafft also man
hat eine gemeinschaft der gläubigen dann
hergestellt da fließt und die gläubigen
bilden dann sozusagen eine kleine
gemeinschaft wendet sich also vom
absoluten ab und das absolute hat
dadurch gar keine möglichkeit mehr sich
zu offenbaren sich zu uns zu kommen
und wenn man das äußerlich betrachtet
also die religion werden immer mehr zu
einem parteien ersatz also sie begleiten
politik und das und dann nochmal
nietzsche zu zitieren
der nimmt das dann das grunzen der moral
also man will es besser wissen mann mann
mann mann mann verglichen werden zum
grenzen der moral in der kirche ist wird
eine politische institution wie sie ja
und nicht mehr dieses ausrichten nachdem
ist herr jung an man könnte doch sagen
ich meine es gibt
ich stelle mir vor es gibt viele viele
gläubige die versammeln sich gemeinsam
die bauen vielleicht nicht einmal ein
priester dabei die beten gemeinsam oder
machen vielleicht auch gemeinsam musik
sie haben ja betont das göttliche muss
nicht zwingend in einer religion
stattfinden sondern man kann gemeinsam
in einem chor singen aber ihnen ist es
ganz wichtig dass es diese ausrichtung
auf die symbole hingibt wenn nicht ich
verstehe und ganz zentral bei ihnen ist
ja auch dieses kreuz sie sagen immer
wieder hört auf die kreuze abzumontieren
nein ich glaube da gibt es zwei
verschiedene ideen wenn ich das einfach
mal so in den raum stellen darf dort
können wir beide diskutieren dass eine
glaube ich ist so etwas wie das sie
sagen das ist christliche kultur
was brauchen wir das andere ist aber
auch so etwas wie das kreuz ist etwas
widerständiges das erzählt nämlich vom
leiden und wir sind nicht mehr bereit
dahin zu gucken wir machen das kreuz weg
wellness oase wie gehen wir mit diesem
er
punkt ich nehme mal den krebs weg warum
brauchen wir das kreuz das war auch
wolfgang einklang co
wenn man ernsthaft erkrankt der macht
eine eigenartige erfahrung nämlich eine
erniedrigung und eine erhöhung zugleich
also wann ich bin zum beispiel völlig
gesund in den uni spital zürich hinein
spaziert und er war 24 stunden später
ein völlig hilfloses wesen das ist auch
eine operation nach einer operation das
erfährt man erst mal als erniedrigung
also man kann nicht mal mehr zum glas
greifen um wasser zu trinken auf der
anderen seite macht man eine ungeheure
erfahrung auch vielleicht den schmerz
und das ist dann eine erhöhung wenn ich
jetzt das kreuz sich ansehen dann haben
sie einerseits sagen den bischofsstab
also dass machtsymbol dass die
senkrechte die erhöhung und gleichzeitig
also den querstrich so etwas wie die
erniedrigung das heißt edel der eine
lite erfahrung macht sieht sich im kreuz
mit dieser erfahrung repräsentiert das
zeichen ob er das ob ihnen das bewusst
ist oder nicht das zeichen teil team das
mit und warum hat dieses zeichen so eine
kraft
dann müsste man dann wieder in die
geschichte der symbole gehen
das kreuz gehört zu den universellen
symbol das ist auch das symbol des todes
eine abwehr von uns hat damit zu tun
dass wir den tod fürchten klein
holzschneiders ab wir fürchten heute den
tod sowie das mittelalter den teufel
gefürchtet hat also wollen wir von
diesem zeichen nichts mehr sehen
dabei könnte uns gerade das zeichen
helfen angst abzubauen
wie genau erzählen sie mal wie ihnen das
kreuz ist wie mir das hilft in dem es
eben auch ein lebensbaum ist das war's
also das kreuz
ist ein symbol dass ich aus erde wasser
luft und licht zusammensetzt es kommt
aus dem holz es ist der baum
das war ursprünglich der lebensbaum muss
sich vorstellen die den sie ursprünglich
entschuldigen kritischen zeiten wichtig
ist also die die menge mussten jagen es
war furchtbar schwierig also dann diese
wilden tiere zu erlegen fleisch nach
hause zu bringen
und da bist bäume und die bäume haben
die menschen beschenkt gar nicht wüssten
die der baum war immer dann ein symbol
auch für die frau für die gebühren für
die geier für die erde
die spenderin und dass dieser lebensbaum
ist im kreuz drin
das ist beides zugleich
ein lebensbaum und ein totem holz als in
mittelalterlichen gedichten wird zum
beispiel der baum als frau angesprochen
auch teilweise das kreuz cg jung hat den
verrückten satz jesus hat eigentlich an
seiner mutter gehören deshalb sind nur
in einem evangelischen überhaupt auf dem
kalvarienberg anwesend dass wir alle
müssen uns sozusagen von einem
lebensbaum lösen wir müssen
selbstständig werden und dann aber
gleichzeitig in dieses toten holz in
diesen sagt er in ihren riesigen
hintergrund der klosterschüler steckt
noch tief in sie wissen unglaublich viel
über alle diese symbole und das bedeutet
ihnen ganz viel
nun ist das aber nicht mehr für alle
leute so und die frage ist ja wie gehen
wir mit diesem kreuz und das sind sie
vielleicht bei der politischen frage
auch wenn die gesellschaft
multikulturell irrt wenn
unterschiedliche menschen zusammenleben
die ganz unterschiedliche geschichten
und hintergründe haben
und da gibt es immer die diskussion über
das gipfelkreuz was man ja auch immer
mal wieder bestätigt hat die wirkung
total abmontiert der berühmte
bergsteiger reinhold messner hat man
gesagt die möblierung der alpen könne
ihm gestohlen bleiben aber grundsätzlich
hätten religiöse symbole nichts zu
suchen
den bergen und da gab es einen
appenzeller künstler der heißt christian
meyer und der hat mal in einer nacht und
nebelaktion im alpstein einen
leuchtenden halbmond montiert haben wir
sehen hier
wenn dir das bild kriegen auf jeden fall
hat dieser künstler hier ist es sehen
diesen haben und dahin getan weil sich
der kunstaktion aber grundsätzlich wenn
sie sagen wir wollen kreuze haben
könnten das auch abwechseln und da dann
auch so ein halbmond weil dieses symbol
ist ja für andere menschen
wahrscheinlich das was für uns das kreuz
ist ja meine dass das ist ja durchaus
möglich auch ein haus ein zeichen zu
benutzen das sinkt ausbrennt ist also
dass mir ein übergang anbietet oder das
dem absoluten ein zugang zu mir bietet
den halbmond haben sind zum beispiel
auch zu füßen von maria also die steht
im katholischen land wissen auf einer
mondsichel und aber warum für uns das
kreuz
ich glaube das hat zum einen durchaus
kulturelle gründe
das kreuz wurde zum zeichen des
abendlandes aber wenn man sich jetzt
vorhat warum gerade dieses zeichen
dann muss man wahrscheinlich auch mit
religionsforschung wie wird für elia de
daneben sehen dass es sehr vieles von
dem repräsentiert in sich zusammen fast
was uns auch bestimmt zum beispiel das
geviert die zahl findet das
koordinatensystem wir haben vier
jahreszeiten also die ursprüngliche
hannes vier elemente und so weiter
wo heute noch in einem quartier trinken
ein viertel ein
es geht um es gibt ein paar läufe und so
weiter also die die vier ist ist die
heilige zahl der peter burri und sie
wird jetzt in diesem kreuz auch ist
darin auch enthalten das ist sie im
haupt- und nicht und er bereits leicht
anderes enthalten
natürlich weiß auch draußen leben ja
auch mit uns zu sagen und wollen jedes
symbol jahren aber wir sind das
abendland und das abendland kommt aus
der griechischen philosophie und aus dem
aus der christlichen und jüdischen
religion und diese und da haben sie eben
dann in diesem zeichen der christen ist
das alles im prinzip zusammengefasst das
heißt dieses zeichen sind wir so wie wir
ein schweizerkreuz haben und dann macht
eben dieses kreuz und schweizer aus und
ich plädiere dafür diese kreuze zu
behalten denn zuerst gehen die zeichen
und wenn die zeichen weg sind dann gehen
auch wir das ist in der geschichte immer
schon so gewesen
ich habe vorhin gesagt sozusagen die
philosophie des abendlandes sei
christlich oder sie haben das in
zusammenhang gebracht naja ich meinen
ganz ganz viele philosophische figuren
haben wir aus einem kulturraum der heute
habe ich ist ja sicher aber das was uns
bestimmt nämlich nur die sprache die
politischen systeme demokratie und so
weiter aber die art und weise unseres
denkens das ist abendländisch dagegen
ist ja nietzsche letzten sturm gelaufen
es ist ein denken in gegensätzen in
werth gegensätzen also wir haben geist
und materie
wir haben ganz den tanks und immens wir
sind immer in einer teilung dass das das
abendland hat in metaphysischen
gegensätzen gelebt das ging ja nicht auf
die nerven das wort ja auch nicht hier
ein gott und ich teilen alles
miteinander alles miteinander verbinden
in also kongress zurück konkret werden
kongresssaal zusammenwachsen abstrakt
absurde das heißt ablösen absondern und
also vor diesem absoluten zum konkreten
vorstoßen das war sein verband geht
meiner meinung nach gar nicht denkt hat
immer etwas mitteilen zu tun denken ist
teilen also wenn ich mir etwas vorstelle
dann verlasse ich sozusagen schon mich
selber und gehe in einen anderen im
laufen einig teilen und diese art von
denken als teilen andenken gegensätzen
bis zu regel bis zu marx und soweit und
basis und überwacht das sind wir
das hat uns geprägt darüber könnten wir
wahrscheinlich ganz lange sprechen was
sind wir ein ich glaube wir sind auch
noch ganz viel anderes aber lassen wir
das mal ich würd gerne und ich würde es
gerne so sagen was wir sind da ist ja
noch nicht wozu wir recht haben andere
dann dazu zu zwingen oder ihnen die
sachen aufzudrücken
und ich glaube in diesem kontext ist es
wichtig vielleicht sich darüber zu
unterhalten wie weit sollte den toleranz
gehen weil es ist ja nun mal so was
verändert sich ganz viel es kommen
menschen zu uns die eben andere
vorstellungen haben vielleicht sind die
wertvorstellung gar nicht so anders aber
vielleicht sind die art und weise wie
man die werte zum ausdruck bringt sehr
unterschiedlich auf jeden fall ist
möglicherweise der religiöse hintergrund
auch ein anderer
und in diesem zusammenhang warnen sie
auch immer wieder sie haben zum beispiel
die figur des toleranz las immer wieder
zitierten gesagt der toleranz
hat er treibt einfach zu weit der ist
gegen die ich habe ein paar sachen mir
ausgeschrieben ist religiös amt die
faschistisch antikapitalistisch öko
fixiert sozialistisch und so weiter und
der missfällt ihnen ganz stark diese
toleranz
die frage ist ja wie man darauf reagiert
und eine idee wäre ja sich zu sagen na
ja wir umarmen das und die andere
möglichkeit sich zu sagen stopp
ich ziehe eine grenze ich glaube sie
plädieren stück weit für grenzen
vielleicht können sie kurz haben warum
sie das tun oder wo glauben sie darf die
grenze nicht eingerissen werden
ja ich kann in eine ganz kurze
geschichte erzählen ich war in meiner
jugend von 24 bis 34 habe ich in einer
mietskaserne in berlin-kreuzberg gelebt
ich habe ja fast ein oder eigentlich
einen türkischen namen höher heißt wie
man heißt hafen also ich war eher
freihafen aus heidiland und der damals
lief heide und und die kinder haben bei
mir geklingelt und wollten mal den an
sind aus diesem jahr kommt mit den kühen
der haut und schokolade hatte natürlich
musste ich haben also die die und das
war eine wunderbare wohngemeinschaft
eigentlich viele dieser familien haben
bei mir telefoniert ich war damals einer
der wenigen maus und der einzige der
telefon hatte
sie haben mich zum essen eingeladen dann
entstand und das auswahl einer tory zur
straße und auf dem gar nicht zur
bahnhofgelände entstand dann die erste
moschee muss vielleicht vorher noch dazu
sagen dass die frau über mir da die
riefen die kinder an und ich dachte die
heißt alle in meiner blödheit und habe
sich dann auch alle genannt das heißt
also die das war meine erste und alle
dass das das waren wir haben sie sich
gefragt warum alles gut wir haben uns
blendend stand eines tages kaum gewohnt
diese alle zu mir und sagte der immer
mal gesagt du darfst meine mutter nicht
mehr grüßen gesagt was ist denn los
nein da hast du nicht also wenn ein
heide wie du deine mutter also ein
ungläubiger see grüßt dann ist das eine
verletzung für
von dem moment an hat sich die
atmosphäre in diesem haus vorsätzlich
verändert und das war nicht so dass
diese leute das so ohne weiteres und mit
freunden einfach dann durch gelebt haben
wie es ihnen befohlen wurde
ich habe dafür auch ein gewisses
verständnis wenn man in der fremde ist
dann dann neigt man dazu hat zu sagen
dinge aus der heimat zu übertreiben und
und und zum beispiel also wenn ich das
noch kurz auf ein türkischer arzt bei
dem ich ab und zu war in kreuzberg auch
in berlin der hat dann seine kinder zur
großmutter gegeben nach istanbul
weil das hatte hier ist mir die luft zu
fundamentalistisch also muss man immer
wieder sehen dass das dass immigranten
natürlich auch etwas mitbringen dass der
natürlichen bogen verlassen hat also
gerade im religiösen und dann zur
übertreibung neigt und da sage ich ganz
klar da ist eine grenze das habe ich
damals auch vertreten in diesem haus das
ist ein tolles haus und ihr sagt man
sich im treppenhaus mit guten tag ich
bin nicht bereit mir von ihm das
verbieten zu lassen
das ist ja auch ein interessantes
phänomen oder wie gehen die um mit
veränderung sie haben jetzt sehr schön
beschrieben die sache verändert sich
ihre grenze der toleranz ist da erreicht
wo sie gezwungen sind sich mit zu
verändern
ein stück weit und in diesem
zusammenhang kann mir jetzt gerade ganz
neu das buch von ulrich greiner in die
hand ulrich kainer hat ein buch
geschrieben heimatlos bekenntnisse eines
konservativen und in diesem buch
beschreibt ulrich greiner eigentlich
glaube ich sehr genau das was sie auch
erzählen und er sagt zb diesen schönen
satz er sagt er fühlt sich mit der zeit
nicht mehr in deckung
in vielerlei hinsicht geht es ihnen auch
so
ja man kann sich natürlich auch mit der
zeit sozusagen identifizieren wenn man
wenn man gegen sie steht also dass wenn
man wenn man da einen gewissen
widerstand hineingerät das ist auch eine
verbindung zur zeit aber da ist
natürlich muss das einer so sein ich
versuche mich oder aber öfter versucht
in meinem leben mich gewissen
veränderungen auszusetzen das
unnatürlich ist können wir nicht
erstarren
dann sind wir tot wir müssen uns also
immer wieder bewegen wir müssen uns
immer wieder verändern aber eine
veränderung das ist nur dann möglich
wenn ich von einem bestimmten standort
aus mich verändere das wiederum
nietzsche dass er hat gesagt das
gefährliche an die helis muss ist dass
der himmel ist alles ab was letztlich
auch die warte auf der es steht also
erfriert den ort von dem her denkt das
ist gefährlich das ist der absturz ins
bodenlose das heißt ich muss etwas
tiefer jemand bleiben sowieso vorbei und
unsere identität ja ich muss einen ort
einnehmen von dem aus ich denken kann
von dem aus ich dann auch mich verändern
kann wenn ich den ort abschaffe auf den
stehen wenn ich die warte abschaffe auf
der ich stehe dann verschwinde ich im
bodenlosen genau das geht natürlich für
alle auch für die die zu uns kommen die
wollen auch ihren orts und ihre
identität bewahren
aber wenn ihr bei diesem bild noch
bleiben was mir sehr gut gefällt da kann
ja sagen der konservative der muss sich
überlegen wie er das was er isst was ihm
wichtig ist was ihm heilig ist können
wir auch sagen wer das bewahren kann da
gibt es diesen schönen satz konservativ
sein heißt die flamme zu bewahren um
nicht die asche zu behüten finde ich ein
wunderbares bild
was ist für sie die flamme was ist die
frage wofür brennen sie und wofür wollen
sie das
unsere kultur bringt ich möchte da ein
anderes bild ergeben dann auch wo ich
denke da kommen wir alle irgendwie her
wir sind ja ein autoland und also der
der eltern dessen er hat so etwas wie
eine mobile heimat oder hat sie heute
noch ist
dann geht er mit kühlen im frühling auf
die halbe höhe und im sommer geht er
dann bis ganz nach oben
überall wo irgendwelche vorrats höhe
das ist die entstehung des
bankgeheimnisses des ressorts und wenn
er ganz oben ist oder wenn er wenn er
wenn er dann sozusagen das land über
sieht dann hat er den eigentlichen ort
eingenommen der eltern spricht dann in
einer art von beschwörung denn den
absägen das ist nichts anderes als der
versuch jetzt von diesem ort aus denn er
einnimmt zum großen ganzen einen bezug
herzustellen das heißt für ihn ist
heimat horizont und ein ausblick und
sozusagen wenn sie jetzt da von der von
der von der flamme reden seine flammende
rede in der dämmerung an dieses land in
die weite dieses landes auch in die
nacht hinein von der ja nicht weiß was
sie mit ihm macht wird er vielleicht
auch angst hat das ist seine heimat
dieses verhältnis also dieser ruf dieser
ausblick das ist nicht nur ein sich
einschließen 1 1
eingeschlossen hat es eine
nahrungsmittel das ist dann seinen
tresor und das hat ihn vielleicht leicht
gemacht aber das hilft ihm nicht
es hilft ihm nur zu sagen der gesang den
er über das land hing heimat heimat ist
horizont das sind schönes bild
wahrscheinlich könnten wir jetzt darüber
noch lange sprechen und überlegen ob das
nicht vielleicht ein bild wäre was
tatsächlich dann auch kulturen verbinden
kann wenn heimat horizont sein kann
aber ich habe ihnen versprochen dass sie
auch noch über ihre literatur sprechen
und das sollten wir unbedingt auch noch
tun sie aus großer schriftsteller und
sie haben ja auch mal gesagt und da
kommt auch der bogen her warum ich
dieses buch so sehr als kondensat ihres
schaffens finde oder empfinde sie sagen
literatur und religion haben eigentlich
ganz viel gemeinsam beide suchen nach
gott und beide suche nach der seele
das müssen sie glaube ich noch einmal
erklären ich glaube sie haben am anfang
schon damit angefangen hat sie gesagt
haben wenn man ein buch liest dann
braucht man fantasie und eigentlich hab
das auch wieder was zu tun mit der
sehnsucht nach den ideen macht dem
transzendenten ja ganz genau
es ist ja so ein auto der will ein
eine kleine welt oder auch eine größe
oder eine figur erschaffen
das heißt er braucht so etwas wie den
glauben dass ihnen das gelingt da ist er
dann bereits zusammenhang vom
zusammenhang ist also ein auto leisten
und also das ist das ist aber ich meine
eigentlich genau das was sie noch mal
angesprochen haben dass man versucht
eine art von entwurf zu schaffen also
ich entwerfe mich aus dem was ich bin in
eine andere welt hinein jetzt kleide ich
diese welt mit wörtern oder mit tönen
oder mit farben aus und versuche dann so
auf diese weise einen übergangen das ist
ein trend and vorgang also und warum ist
der übergang wichtig weil er letztlich
von unsere kleinen eng welt weg führt
ins große ganze also wir lernen da so
einen schritt zu tun also über eine eine
brücke zu gehen und dass das macht jeder
leser das macht darauf dass machen sonst
an die auch die leute die uns jetzt zu
hören in dem moment was ich dann von der
flamme sprechen oder sich vom 10
entstehen bilder das heißt man steigt in
dieser vollständigkeit von ihnen selber
designen platonischer sie produzieren
eine art scheinwelt sind mit ihren
büchern auf die man sich dann ein lassen
kann
ja und sie also wir reden ja auch in
diesem zusammenhang von erscheinungen
das hat die deutsche brauchen beratung
übernommen
die eigentliche wirklichkeit ist bei den
ideen und also es gibt das glas an sich
das ist das wahre glas und das ist dann
eben das eine erscheinung dieses waren
blase
wir sind wirksam abbild wir sind
erscheinungen ausfluss von ideen von
archetypen und ja daran also da bin ich
eigentlich im laufe meines lebens bin
ich von dieser welt sehr pompös
verabschiedet und bin dann ganz klein
und demütig wieder dahin zurück
gekrochen
mit regenschirm ihre neueste figur die
sie beschäftigt das haben sie schon
angetönt ich ja casanova
sie haben ein stück geschrieben das
feiert premiere am 19 oktober in
einsiedeln wieder unter der regie von
barbara schlumpf wieder die gleiche
theater truppe wie schon franzosen übrig
also die gleiche regisseurin und in
diesem stück geht es tatsächlich um
diesen casanova und casanova war ja
nicht nur ein großer frauenheld und
verführer und betrüger und spieler und
was weiß ich noch alles sondern war auch
ein großer reisender und auf dieser
reise kam er auch nach zürich und bis
nach einsiedeln wo er offenbar was ich
nicht wusste sondern von ihnen wird
verfahren habe tatsächlich möglich
werden wollte casanova war dann
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen müde
er wurde auch verfolgt er hat den
stuttgart riesige spielstunden gemacht
heisst natürlich super ins kloster zu
flüchten
er hat gedacht also groß warum so bauen
kann ein metaphysisches zappeln bei ihm
sondern nur sich verstecken sich
versteckt und er hat damals
wahrscheinlich schon mit dem waren
gespielt mir morgen zu schreiben
also er hat ja sich eigentlich
schriftlich erfunden das ist ja eine
ganz große
es ist jetzt das gelungen was wir wollen
angesprochen haben ihr habt einen
archetypen geschaffen den verführer
aber vielleicht gar nicht so sehr im
leben vielleicht er da in sein altes
leben ja was hätten sie vielleicht gerne
so wie ja kann sein kann sie aber aber
es gibt diese episode und als dann eben
diese theatergruppe den einzigen
gewinnen gefragt hat ob ich nicht an
eine idee hätte einen 108 erhoben
und dann gibt es eben das ist der diener
von casanova das ist die leseprobe
sitzen alle auf der bühne wir spielen in
einem alten kino kino hetzel also mit
sehr bequemen stühlen und das sind
teilweise schlumpf mit den menschen die
dann eben darüber diskutieren müssen ob
sie nicht richtig gemein ist auch nicht
ausspielen die schauspielerin ja ja ja
auch noch was sie könnten wir nicht den
menschen
die und und theater lebt ja immer von
den gegebenheiten also das muss ja
irgendwie zusammen kommen zusammen
passen und mit meinem alten freund
zerschneidung er ist eine hervorragende
arzt und onkologie und der passt
wunderbar auf diese figur da kam also
aus zusammen das dorf hat erfahrungen
mit dem kloster können wir eigentlich
aus dem etwas daraus ein ein stück
knochen jetzt der casanova der ich ja
ein stück weit hin und hergerissen auch
zwischen dieser leidenschaft irdische
leidenschaft und andererseits eben diese
sehnsucht der plötzlich im auto hat er
sich verstecken aber sie dichten ihm
zumindest auch ein stück weit anders ja
auch eine leidenschaft hat fürs
metaphysische und ich habe mich
tatsächlich gefragt sind sie selber ein
bisschen so ein casanova der diese
beiden sehnsüchte in sich hat die
nietzsche sozusagen in sich zusammen
schließen wollte in dem eben ein schirm
zugemacht hat aber sie haben beides
immer noch sie haben den schirm
einerseits die metaphysik und an
aber auch ein stück weit die sehnsucht
nach dem schönen nach der kunst das dass
das schöne was sie auch reist ja es hat
vielleicht etwas mit dem zu tun was wir
vorher angesprochen haben ich glaube
ohne metaphysik kann man nicht lieben
also die die dass das dass die die und
und also casanova mal ein großer lieben
er hat sich immer wieder verliebt er hat
die frauen angebetet und er hatte
deshalb auch sofort ein verhältnis zur
madonna italiener der war das war dann
für ihn die mutter mama und also da wäre
er sofort gerne geblieben aber auch wenn
man die die die geschichte seines lebens
wenn man die verschiedenen liebschaften
betrachtete ich ihn nicht kalt das ist
weit weg also er war wahrscheinlich bis
zu einem gewissen grade einmal pro tag
also in der anbetung sind ihm die frauen
erleben also er hat die nie
er hat er war jetzt nicht ein los morgen
dachte er haupt micro verein führte und
die suche durch gute das absolute und
und er hat die tatsächlich nicht
gefunden das wird in den einzigen eine
rolle spielen also pausen oder kommt
dann nach einigen wenig kostet und jetzt
muss er zurück in den frauen ins hotel
und warten und in dieser nacht begegnet
er ein mädchen und plötzlich denkt er
das wäre sie gewesen die von allen nach
wer ihn also das wäre ihm eine an imam
gewesen ich habe sich an allen gesuchten
keine gewöhnliche jetzt hätte ich sie
wie das dann ausgeht dass erfahrungen
sind einzig noch keiner sehr herzlich
eingeladen sind
vielen dank zum schluss herr lehmann
noch ein satz von ihnen der letzte satz
ihres buches vielleicht ein schönes
vielleicht sind wir bestimmter sie ahnen
damit glaube ich möchte ich gerne
schließen herr juli man ganz ganz
herzlich
für dieses gespräch nicht regeln hier
studio danke dass sie hier waren
ich danke ihm ja nächste woche wie jetzt
hier ernst wir reden übers klima mein
kollege lynch post spricht mit al gore
der am zürcher filmfestival seinen neuen
film über den klimawandel vorgestellt
hat eine woche drauf vertiefe ich das
thema am philosophischen stammtisch im
sud in basel
und jetzt gleich erzählen die ihnen in
der sternstunde kunst die russische
oktoberrevolution neu nämlich aus der
sicht von künstlerinnen und künstlern
wie erlebten sie die turbulente zeit und
welche rolle spielten sie darin
karin rotes film der ware oktober
sollten sie auf keinen fall verpassen
danke fürs interesse und einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]